[Musik]
mehr als 1000 inseln gegen im
sankt-lorenz-strom ihre schönheit und
ihre legenden faszinieren die menschen
seit jahrhunderten
vom wasser und aus der luft sind sie am
besten zu entdecken
die unzähligen felsbrocken sind kleine
wunder der natur
[Musik]
[Applaus]
1000 islands heißt eine der
beeindruckendsten regionen im norden des
amerikanischen kontinents im grenzgebiet
von kanada und den usa
mitten im sankt-lorenz-strom im kleinen
hafen von cannes an en grey herrscht
schon seit den frühen morgenstunden
hochbetrieb
[Musik]
200 sportler aus allen teilen
nordamerikas sind gekommen um am größten
angel wettbewerb der region teilzunehmen
der big boss challenge organisiert von
gary fisher dem präsidenten des
wettbewerbs
[Musik]
wir starten in fünf bis zehn minuten um
5 uhr 30 die kleinen boote um sechs die
großen
wir gucken dass jeder angemeldet ist und
wir werden das hier rocken und einen
guten tag haben
heute ist der grosse final tag zwei tage
lang konkurrieren die andere darum wer
den größten barsch aus dem fluss holt 60
dollar zahlen sie für die teilnahme als
das lokale tourismus büro vor fünf
jahren beschloss den wettbewerb ins
leben zu rufen war schnell klar wer ihn
leiten soll
ich fühle mich total gut und kann es gar
nicht abwarten die gewinne zu vergeben
die jungs wissen dass ich lieber selbst
fischen oder als zuzugucken
aber gary wir brauchen dich jemand muss
das ganze organisieren
ja das ist wohl so
[Musik]
gary ist leidenschaftlicher angler doch
heute vergibt ja nur die preise
jede volle stunde gibt es einen sieger
und 500 dollar und am ende den
hauptgewinn für den dicksten fisch des
wochenendes sehr stolz auf das was ich
nicht dass liebe zum sport ich liebe es
etwas für die gemeinde zu tun
respektiert zu werden
ich gehe die straße runter und jeder
sagt harry die ich liebe das
die ersten andere sind schon nach einer
halben stunde wieder zurück sobald es
hell wird kommt die fische hoch und
beißen
jedes boot hat einen extra
transportbehälter für den fang abliefern
dürfen sie die branche nur lebend ob
ihre fische unter den gewinnern sind
entscheidet sich auf der waage
es geht jetzt schlag auf schlag
419 fische werden an diesem wochenende
gefangen begutachtet gehoben registriert
und am ende wieder in die freiheit
entlassen
[Musik]
wir essen die fischer nicht mehr damit
sie nicht aussterben
wir kennen und verschonen sie mich einen
fisch fangen dann schaue ich mir an was
auch immer aber ich will dass diesen
fisch auch mein enkel da drüben anfangen
kann dann wird er ein stück größer sein
wenn ihn fängt und das ist der grund
warum wir die fische nicht mehr essen
dass hier in zukunft noch viele fische
zu finden sind dafür kämpft auch ein
paar kilometer weiter flussabwärts der
pausen teilens national park
der älteste nationalpark kanadas umfasst
21 inseln und ist mit 24
quadratkilometern zwar einer der
kleinsten aber auch einer der
artenreichsten
damit dies so bleibt kümmern sich hier
29 granger um die insgesamt über 40
bedrohten tier und pflanzenarten
[Musik]
ich würde mich selbst als so etwas wie
einen fisch nerd bezeichnet was diese
region hier so einzigartig macht unser
park hat die größte vielfalt in kanada
über 100 arten süßwasserfische gibt es
ja jetzt um uns herum mindestens 25 bis
30 die unterschiedliche landschaft
tiefwasser die untiefen sumpfgebiet all
das sorgt für einzigartige
voraussetzungen unsere aufgabe ist es
bei all diesen vielen unterschiedlichen
fischarten sicherzustellen dass vielfalt
und artenreichtum für immer bleiben
dafür kontrollieren sie an 20
ausgewählten stellen im
sankt-lorenz-strom mehrfach im jahr den
fischbestand und das nun schon seit über
zehn jahren
so verschaffen sie sich einen überblick
wie sich die einzelnen fischarten
entwickeln und wie gefährdet sie sind
allein in diesem netz haben wir schon
fünf unterschiedliche fischer
das hier ist der ehren fisch daher wie
ein salzwasser fisch aussieht er
schwimmt knapp unter der
wasseroberfläche das ist toll diese
kleinen burschen hier heißen zahn
kämpfen von denen gibt es hier überall
sehr viele größere fische essen sie
gerne jede fischart wird nach anzahl und
größe protokolliert
hier haben wir einfluss barsch und 115 1
sie achten besonders auf fremde
eingedrungene arten wie den schwarz mond
grundl größere fische essen ihn nicht
alltäglich schmeckt und so hatten die
ranger in der vergangenheit oft bis zu
zwölf fische in so einem netz wir haben
heute nur einen im netz das ist
überraschend
sie sind in den ballast wassertanks der
großen schiffe hierhergekommen quer über
den atlantik
die tanks wurden dann hier gelehrt und
fesche wie der schwarze und grundl haben
so ihren weg in unser ökosystem gefunden
einige arten machen keine probleme der
schwarze hund grunde schon die kleinen
heimischen fische die ähnlich zu ihm
sind werden durch ihn verdrängt oder
sich hier so schnell vermehrt die
leichen vier bis fünf mal im jahr wo
hingegen die heimischen fische dies nur
ein bis zweimal machen
innerhalb der letzten zehn jahre hatte
sich zu einer der dominantesten
fischarten im fluss entwickelt und
leider wissen wir immer noch nicht was
es für langfristige folgen haben wird
um die einzigartige flora und fauna
sowie den gefährdeten baumbestand auch
ihren 21 inseln zu schützen betätigen
sich die ranger als brandstifter
[Musik]
auf der insel käme lockt bereiten
derrick und josh für die weiß ständige
kiefer ein kontrolliertes feuer vor
[Musik]
wir haben hier schon letzten frühling
mit der arbeit angefangen vor allem
schneider arbeiten
wir haben die rivalisierenden bäume
heraus geschnitten damit genügend licht
auf den boden fällt und haben das ganze
brennbare material auf dem waldboden so
präpariert dass das feuer stark genug
ist und die kiefern wachsen können und
das geht am besten indem an
mineralischen nährstoffreichen asche
früher gab es viele natürliche feuer
heutzutage kaum noch
die weiß ständige kiefer ist einzigartig
wir sind der einzige park in kanada in
dem sie sechs ist die nördlichste grenze
ihrer ausbreitung maler weise findet man
sie viel weiter südlich in den
vereinigten staaten diese arten an den
äußeren rändern ihres natürlichen
vorkommens erhalten die artenvielfalt
die müssen unbedingt erhalten bleiben
solche dinge wie den klimawandel die
verbreitung von krankheiten durch das
eindringen fremder arten zu verhindern
wie hier die weiß stimmige kiefer ein
idealer ort um die artenvielfalt und die
region zu begreifen liegt oberhalb von
landenberg in zentrum der 1000 inseln ja
don ross vom fronten ikarus fairen
reservat nicht nur den besten überblick
er steht auch auf dem ältesten gestein
der erde milliarden jahre alter granit
hier und da sind diese felsigen kippen
in der landschaft eiszeit und dem wetter
über milliarden jahre getrotzt haben sie
sind das rückgrat der mutter erde wie
die ureinwohner sind aber sie sind auch
der grund warum die 1000 inseln hier
sind die 1000 inseln sind in
wirklichkeit 1000 bergspitzen eines
alten gebirges der ontariosee ist so
hoch gestiegen dass er über den fronten
eck bogen in dieses tal geflossen ist
und so wurden 1000 bergkuppen 1000
inseln
frontex bei 14 ist eines von 18
biosphärenreservaten der unesco in
kanada jedes jahr im sommer organisiert
das netzwerk ein feriencamp für kinder
von 6 bis 11
[Musik]
die kinder sind ein wichtiger teil der
gesellschaft ein grund warum will das
biosphären natur kämpfen zwölf jahren
ins leben gerufen haben ist dass auch
sehr junge kinder schon über ihre umwelt
nachdem soll und die hoffnung ist dass
sie da hinein wachsen
[Musik]
ziel der umweltschützer ist es die
begeisterung der kinder für ihre direkte
umgebung zu wecken
allein hier im reservat treffen fünf
verschiedene wälder aufeinander und
sorgen für eine hohe artenvielfalt don
ross will die kinder für die spuren in
der natur sensibilisieren
hier ist es seht euch das an die wundert
euch sicher über die größeren holzstücke
die ein biber auf einmal abreißen und
seht ihr dies ist jeweils ein biber bis
jedes mal wenn er damit seinen zähnen
abweist sind es stücke von lisa größe
könnt ihr euch vorstellen dass mit euren
zähnen zu machen können eure mama und
papa das mit ihren zellen
[Musik]
zurück in kanada play 2,54 diana bemühen
sich mit den fischen schonend umzugehen
bieten ein schnelles erinnerungsfoto und
dann geht es zurück in den strom
die barsche werden dort ausgesetzt wo
sie gefangen wurden
für die fische bedeutet diese prozedur
stress in der regel aber überstehen sie
es folgenlos und nur um verletzte tiere
werden wieder ausgesetzt
[Musik]
dieser fisch ist von ganz tief unten im
wasser zu schnell nach oben gebracht
worden
deshalb ist seine schwimmblase
aufgebläht was wir jetzt machen ist wir
nehmen meine nadel stechen sie ein und
lassen etwas luft aus der blase dass er
wieder gerade schwimmt just endlich
brauche hilfe
erst wenn die schwimmblase wieder
funktioniert hat der barsch eine
überlebenschance
sie sorgt für das gleichgewicht gary ist
leidenschaftlicher angler und weiß wie
er mit dem fisch umgehen muss da sind
sie gar sind da kommt die luft raus
siehst du die blasen
ich lasse nicht die ganze luft raus nur
einen teil damit seine blase schmaler
wird dass er sich wieder aufrichten kann
und dann schwingt er wieder ein echter
sieger aber nicht der schwerste fisch an
diesem tag der kommt in der letzten
stunde des wettbewerbs und gary hat
schon so eine ahnung dass er es sein
könnte
wieden ist jetzt chefsache
[Musik]
tatsächlich der war springt deutlich
über sechs pfund auf die waage
schwerer war an diesem wochenende keine
nach dem erinnerungsfoto geht es direkt
zur preisverleihung
[Musik]
wir haben null fische verloren weil ihr
aufgepasst habt gary bled nur die ehre
für den gewinner aber gibt es einen
check 3000 dollar für den dicksten fisch
des wettbewerbes
der nächste morgen in der industrie
schwachen region ist neben dem tourismus
vor allem die landwirtschaft ein
wichtiger wirtschaftsfaktor 50 kilometer
von hannover entfernt betreiben chris
und mary wedding einen kleinen bio
bauernhof vor fünf jahren hat der 54
jährige seinen job als computersystem
analyst an den nagel gehängt
warum ich jetzt als bauarbeiter liegt an
zwei sachen die
telekommunikationsbranche nichts gutes
für die welt
ich wollte aber etwas machen was hilft
die welt besser zu machen
zweitens hatten wir einen großen garten
für uns selbst angelegt es wuchs dort
aber so viel gemüse das wir angefangen
haben es auf dem markt zu verkaufen
und die nachfrage nach seinen produkten
wächst stetig so hat er seit kurzem auch
ein paar helfer für die sommermonate in
denen deutlich mehr arbeit anfällt
dann hilft auch seine frau mary himmelt
die eigentlich für die provinzregierung
in kisten arbeitet
eine besonderheit ist sein saatgut das
gleiche mit dem schon die ersten siedler
ihre felder bestellt haben
[Musik]
es reicht zurück bis ins 17 jahrhundert
die meisten modernen getreidearten
wurden erst nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
angebot und waren bestandteil der grünen
revolution um den höchstmöglichen
ernteertrag zu erzielen wurden
düngemittel eingesetzt
dadurch sind sie nun ein wenig
degeneriert das rohr getreide jedoch
kann sich den individuellen biologischen
gegebenheiten anpassen
wann bekommt sein individuelles saatgut
welches zum eigenen klima zu der eigenen
temperaturen zum eigenen ackerboden
passt dadurch gewinnt es an
widerstandskraft und wird immer
resistenter gegenüber krankheiten und so
gelingt es uns im prinzip mit der zeit
eine widerstands kräftigere gesündere
gen ressource zu schaffen
der ertrag liegt gerade mal bei 30
prozent im vergleich zu modernen
getreidearten dafür schmeckt es aber
besser und ist auch viel reicher an
proteinen und nährstoffen in der 200
jahre alten steinhügel in delta trottet
er das getreide noch auf die
ursprüngliche methode ohne zusätze
schmeckt es jedes jahr ein bisschen
anders
je nach klima boden und pflanzen
beschaffenheit
analog bay liegt nur 40 kilometer
entfernt
seine nicht gemahlenen weizen liefert
chris hierher an die kleine örtliche
brauerei
braumeister eric will daraus ein ganz
besonderes bier brauen
[Musik]
wir wie es schon die ersten siedler
tranken nur unter hygienischen
bedingungen hergestellt dass aber
trotzdem jedes mal ein bisschen anders
schmeckt
der weizen hat immer ganz
unterschiedliche eigenarten selbst
kommerzielles getreide hat das aber hier
erleben wir es in einer extremen art mit
chris smalling scoren
es ist wirklich total unterschiedlich zu
dem was ich bisher gemacht habe indem er
sein motorrad bio weizen verwenden
erhalten wir immer unterschiedliche
farben und geschmäcker
es wird automatisch jedes mal ein
anderes mir ich nenne es denn gerne noch
mehr geschmack ein einheimischer
geschmack dem es nur hier gibt
[Musik]
gegenüber der brauerei findet im sommer
jeden donnerstag von 16 bis 19 uhr der
farmers market statt
ein umschlagplatz für klatsch und
tratsch in der region
bauern aus der näheren umgebung wie
chris wurde bieten ihre produkte an über
die deutschen touristen freut sich vor
allem harald mix der sein bisonfleisch
verkauft
[Musik]
nach 35 jahren in den pausen teilen kann
er sich eine rückkehr nach deutschland
nicht mehr vorstellen
es ist nicht so überbevölkert ist mehr
laid back river hat motorola ist und mir
gefällt es hier sehr gut wird dann nicht
mehr zurück wollen 15 kilometer
außerhalb von kanal ok betreibt er seine
60 hektar große bison farm neben seinem
job als berufsschullehrer
1992 hat er mit 13 kühen und einem
bullen angefangen mittlerweile hat er 30
bisons und hilft damit die tiere zu
retten die vor 100 jahren fast
ausgerottet wurden aus politischen
gründen um die ureinwohner unter
kontrolle zu halten wurden oft besser
werden abgeschlachtet und von den 60
millionen die es gegeben haben soll
haben wir mehr als 1000 überlebt
inzwischen hat sich der bestand in
nordamerika auf geschätzte 30.000 tiere
stabilisiert harald füttert seine bisons
nur mit wasser und heu wie in der freien
wildbahn ihr fettarmes fleisch ist vor
allem bei gesundheitsbewussten kunden
beliebt doch für die ureinwohner hatte
es eine viel größere bedeutung
hauptinteresse man natürlich ernährung
das fleisch wurde hauptsächlich
getrocknet weil man das ja dann
langfristig über den winter haltbar
machen muss natürlich wurde auch das
leder benutzt und die die fälle um sich
warm zu halten als kleidung knochen und
und und holzschmuck so es war ziemlich
nah & product hat wo alles benutzt wurde
seit drei monaten hat es kaum geregnet
nicht nur die wasserstelle für die tiere
ist ausgetrocknet auch die brunnen haben
immer weniger wasser deswegen muss
harald das wasser jetzt gut einteilen
moment wie man sieht es ist ziemlich
schwierig hier das nicht mehr viel zu
fressen auf der wiese ist alles trocken
wir hatten keinen richtigen regen seit
april
und wie man sieht hier es ist alles
braun dass man jetzt schon wasser von
werden ansehe hierher bringen muss um
die tiere zu trinken noch reicht das
wasser in seinem brunnen
es ist einer der heißesten und
trockensten sommer der letzten
jahrzehnte
erst im september wird es ein paar
regentage geben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch nach seinem ruhestand in sieben
jahren will harald die bisons sucht
weiter betreiben als hobby um davon
leben zu können müsste sie mindestens
zehnmal so groß sein
[Musik]
ein paar wochen später im oktober wenn
die lufttemperatur niedriger ist als die
des wassers bildet sich jeden morgen
eine feine nebel schicht über dem st
lorenz strom morning misst nennen ihn
die einheimischen ein kurzes phänomen
nach wenigen minuten hat die sonne ihn
vertrieben
die kalten temperaturen vertreiben aber
nicht nur die touristen sondern auch die
meisten anwohner im herzen der 1000
inseln tobt im sommer das leben jetzt im
oktober ist alexandra b wie ausgestorben
auch in pausen teilen park gegenüber
haben die bewohner ihre häuser bereits
winterfest verpackt den kalten nächten
verdanken sie aber auch ein besonderes
natur finden hin fällt das thermometer
nachts unter null grad celsius beginn
sich die blätter von gelb bürger rothorn
roteiche und linde zu verfärben
in prächtigen farben indian summer als
diese fünfte jahreszeit
[Musik]
damit beginnt die erntezeit für
commander mit seinem kompagnon chery ist
der kanu bauer auf der suche nach der
richtigen bürger
es ist ein exklusives recht der
nordamerikanischen ureinwohner als hüter
der natur in dem öffentlichen wald bäume
fällen zu dürfen bisschen klein ob
erreicht jack stammt vom berg lang vom
stamm der all gone grill die noch vor
den mohawks und irokesen hier siedelten
ursprünglich ein jeder volk toller bauen
die fast dick genug
5 also 60 zoll testen
die kanu bauer brauchen die rinde der
bürger
doch die muss stabil und dick genug sein
er ist grenzwertig der inde löst sich
nicht gut genug wenn ich die achse
drehen wir brauchen drei millimetern
aber hier haben wir 0 2
vielleicht auch nur 1,5 mm es wäre schon
gut genug wenn wir nicht mit enorm viel
kraft die rinde abziehen müssen
die sorge ist immer dass sie dann dafür
doch nicht stark genug ist besonders da
wo flecken am baum sind
das ist eine schwachstelle da müssen wir
dann hoffen dass die rinde nicht auf
platz deswegen suchen wir auch immer
nach der richtigen blick und die finden
sie dann zum glück ein paar hundert
meter weiter
[Musik]
die amerikanischen ureinwohner sind eng
mit der natur verbunden vor dem fällen
betet chuck und opfert etwas tabak ihm
ist es wichtig auch immer etwas der
natur zurückzugeben
so schließt sich der kreislauf ich
bedanke mich beim schöpfer für das
geschenk das wir erhalten
ich bete dafür dass wir alle gesund
bleiben und danke meiner mutter der erde
die uns mit all dem hier versorgt
gleichzeitig bitte ich die insekten sich
in der bürger leben um ihre vergebung da
ich ihr zuhause zerstören werde
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
wir verwenden die bürger weil es sie
früher reichlich gab sei von natur aus
wasserdicht ist und sehr leicht sie ist
hier ideal als transportmittel auf den
vielen seen strömen und flüssen die es
hier geht
und deswegen haben eine leute und auch
jamie stamm die birken gründen karten
verwendet aus dem rest machen sie später
brennholz nichts wird verschwendet
chuck und larry sind froh dass sie heute
so schnell fündig geworden sind
das ist nicht immer so sie sind immer
schwerer zu finden als ich aufgewachsen
bin in den 70er jahren haben mir meine
großeltern erzählt dass ein baum von 200
eine birke waren heute ist das höchstens
jeder fünf hundertstel oder tausendste
normalerweise fahre ich sehr weit 10 12
manchmal 15 stunden und dann weiß ich
nicht einmal ob das überhaupt eine
passende bürger ist also muss ich da
hinfahren viel geld ausgeben um am ende
meine lehren daraus zu ziehen wenn sie
doch nicht gut war
den glauben der nordamerikanischen
ureinwohner nach filtert die birkel
gifte und schadstoffe aus dem
regenwasser heraus
daher ist die birke für sie ein heiliger
baum aufgrund der steigenden
umweltverschmutzung gibt es aber immer
weniger von ihnen das device stimmige
kiefer nicht ausstirbt dafür sorgen die
männer des 1000 teilens national park
die wetterbedingungen heute sehr gut ja
wir haben auch die richtige windrichtung
auf die wir gewartet haben
die wollen sie heute nutzen um den teil
einer insel in brand zu setzen
zur rettung der kiefer an vorderster
front als die eigene ausrüstung
lebenswichtig in eine der grundlegenden
sachen bei einem waldbrand ist die
kleidung
das ist normalerweise nomex das ist ein
material das feuer resistent ist und vor
hitze schützt an der feuerfront laut
unerträglich heiß genauso wichtig sind
die kommunikationsmittel an der
feuerstelle müssen wir natürlich
miteinander kommunizieren können
das gilt für alle firefighters in
nordamerika wir operieren alle immer 100
dingen einheit aus drei oder vier leute
ok jungs heute nehmen wir mit
ein marktreifes die pumpe mit zubehör
wir können vielleicht noch zwei taschen
b schläuche gebrauchen und nehme auch
die kettensäge die richtige vorbereitung
und ausrüstung sind existenziell
deshalb ist bis jetzt auch immer alles
glimpflich ausgegangen
[Musik]
ihr ziel käme lockt island hier haben
sie vor zwei monaten einen platz für ein
kontrolliertes feuer vorbereitet denn
mit der samen der bedrohten weiß
stämmigen kiefer es leichter hat im
boden zu keimen
[Musik]
mit diesem feuer wollen sie den baum vor
dem aussterben retten
[Musik]
ja ja das klingt tatsächlich
widersprüchlich wenn man darüber
nachdenkt und tatsächlich gibt es einige
bäume die schnell verenden im feuer
aber es gibt baumarten wie die weiß
stämmige kiefer die brauchen feuer oder
ähnliches um sich zu regenerieren
dieser kiefernbestand hier würde von der
landfläche verschiedenen und hatte es
längere zeit kein feuer geben würde
sie brauchen also solche feuer um sich
zu erholen welchen positiven einfluss
feuer auf die entwicklung der natur und
vor allem der bedrohten kiefer haben
kann untersuchen die ranger auf georgina
island
hier haben sie vor zwei jahren ein feuer
gelegt vor einem halben jahr waren sie
das letzte mal auf dieser insel
[Musik]
hier haben sich gut entwickelt
georges was ist ja das ist eine rallye
asb da den hat das feuer richtig gut
getan
vorher gab es davon keine auf der insel
sie haben nur darauf gewartet
unglaublich wie groß die seit dem
letzten mal geworden sind ihm geht es
gut dass hier sieht auch noch an guten
platz aus dass sich sah man setzen
können
genau darum geht es dass die samen der
kiefernzapfen sich in den neuen boden
gut entwickeln
ungefähr 100 samen hat jeder zapfen nach
dem feuer sind sie von besserer qualität
um die entwicklung der vegetation genau
zu protokollieren
legen sie immer an der gleichen
markierten stelle ein quadrat haus
vor dem feuer hat es hier keine kiefern
gegeben
[Musik]
hier haben wir eine weiß stämmige kiefer
die aussaat hat sich gut entwickelt an
dieser stelle
wir haben hier seit dem feuer die aral
ag speed die gab es vorher nicht
stengel 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 bis hierher sie
verstümmelt also im ganzen das macht
zehn prozent der ganzen fläche
ich bin sehr zufrieden wir haben unsere
erwartungen deutlich übertroffen was die
anzahl an weiß ständigen kießling
betrifft das war unser hauptziel
deswegen sind wir sehr glücklich weil
wir jetzt einen ganz neuen bestand an
kiefern haben war die tolle überraschung
heute erlebt haben
neben der kiefer haben sich auch viele
andere pflanzen entwickelt die es hier
vorher nicht gab
wir haben also nicht nur die kiefer
wiederhergestellt sondern auch eine ganz
neue vegetation die ranger im
nationalpark haben es geschafft
auch in zukunft wird die weiß stimmige
kiefer in den 1000 inseln zu finden sein
[Musik]
hannover truck ist in der zwischenzeit
zu hause in seiner freiluft werkstatt
angekommen
weder 20 mal 1 meter zur stabilisierung
und zum schutz für die weiße dünne rinde
der birke weg tag später den innenraum
des kanus mit zedernholz aus er spaltet
es so lange bis es ganz leicht und
flexibel ist handarbeit ist gefragt
wir haben es mit maschinen probieren sie
wissen nicht wenn die maserung so oder
so geht sie gehen einfach gerade durch
aber wenn sie das machen bricht das holz
wenn sie auf eine beule stoßen wenn wir
es auf diese weise machen folgen wir der
maserung und wir müssen uns keine sorgen
machen dass es bricht sieht so aus als
ob wir hier ein tolles großes stück
haben mit zwölf jahren hat er die kunst
des kanu bauens von seinem großvater
gelernt
jetzt ist er stolz dieses wissen an die
nächste generation weiterzugeben
wir machen es für die jüngeren damit sie
involviert sind um sie wieder zurück zu
den wurzeln zu bringen
diese kunst beizubringen die schon fast
ausgestorben war
jack ist vermutlich einer von nur 6 km
machen in ganz kanada
ich denke es ist sehr wichtig dass die
jungen leute die sehen und lernen damit
es nicht verloren geht viele first
nations haben sich in ihre reservate
zurückgezogen
doch das leben dort war nichts wird
chuck daher hatte es vor ein paar jahren
verlassen und sich als kanu bauer
selbstständig gemacht
der rote man unsere ursprüngliche rolle
war es auf das land aufzupassen was uns
genommen
wir wurden in kleine reservate gestellt
viele von uns werden jetzt als indianer
behandelt und durften teilweise gar
nicht mehr in die wälder in den licht
diese arbeit den jungen menschen zeige
denke ich spüren sie den stolz der
schnaps verschwindet die hoffnung kommt
jetzt gehen sie raus in die wälder
arbeiten mit dem forstamt zusammen für
einen gesunden wald
es gab mal einen ältesten der sagte uns
gehört nicht der fall das land wir haben
es nur von unseren kindern gern über
einen monat baut er an einem kanu
stückpreis 14.000 dollar angefangen hat
er mit zwei stück pro jahr
für nächstes jahr hat er bereits sieben
aufträge steuert das fertige kanu vorbei
an den wasserstrudel sie sind das
resultat riesige unterwasser fälle bis
zu 30 meter schießen sie in die tiefe
das ergebnis sind oft gefährliche
strömungen dem mythos der ureinwohner
nach lebt hier ein hässlicher geist der
die menschen in die tiefe zieht hat
besänftigt ihn mit einem opfer
[Musik]
ich habe tabak geopfert und ein gebet
zum schöpfer und dem ding im wasser
gesprochen damit er die menschen
geschützt die hier vorbeikommen
egal von welcher kultur ob weiß rot
schwarz oder gelb
ich habe es für alle kulturen gesprochen
denn nicht nur wir leben hier in diesem
land
das gilt für alle menschen die den
wasserweg benutzen
mitte oktober geht dann auch die saison
auf dem wasser zu ende
gäste und bewohner holen nach und nach
ihre boote an land
[Musik]
in the way findet zu dieser zeit zum
ersten mal ein mahler festival statt
bis zu 40 unterschiedliche künstler
kommen hierher und malen drei tage lang
auf den inseln am hafen und mitten in
der stadt
[Musik]
das kulturelle highlight des herbstes in
der kleinen kanadischen gemeinde ist
auch ein pflichttermin für susi smith
die herausgeberin des online-magazins
1000 island live will mit ihren
geschichten die kleinen gemeinden
zusammen halten und stärken
länderübergreifend
machst du auch noch andere sachen ja ich
bin im chor und in der kirchengemeinde
hauptsächlich musik aber das hier ist
toll weil die küste meine heimat ist und
daher bin ich so froh dass hier endlich
mal was passiert solche veranstaltungen
sind sehr wichtig für die gemeinschaft
der 1000 inseln wir haben eine sehr
kurze saison im juli und august ist
jeder hier und dann gehen alle wieder
nach hause und festivals zu dieser
jahreszeit ermöglichen es den leuten die
noch hier wohnen zusammen zu kommen und
spaß zu haben
nach getaner arbeit fährt sie zurück
nach hause auf ihre eigene insel so sie
ist einer der letzten und ersten
temporären bewohner der 1000 islands
andere inseln sind schon verlassen
manche besitzer vernageln sogar die
fenster ihrer coaches komplett für susi
ist es die schönste jahreszeit
sie ist wunderbar denn der fluss gehört
uns und das bedeutet wir sind die
einzigen die auf dem fluss sind
jeder der nach dem tag der arbeit noch
hier ist sagt uns gehört der fluss und
das ist toll es ist jetzt ruhig
[Musik]
wir wurden als fluss reiten bezeichnet
wegen unserer leidenschaft für den fluss
und weil wir uns für die gemeinschaft
engagieren
ich muss immer lachen denn ich dachte
eine schlussrate ist ein fischer oder
jemand der auf den inseln arbeitet eben
eine echte type
[Musik]
auch auf der amerikanischen seite des st
lorenz stroms beginnen die
vorbereitungen für den bevorstehenden
winter
[Musik]
inzinger kassel holt hausmeisters gott
heute sein winter projekt ein schrank
bett ab er freut sich schon auf die
ruhige monate in denen er endlich viel
zeit für solche restaurationsarbeiten
hat ich habe immer verschiedene projekte
für die winterzeit
das hier ist 1 und ein anderes die
terrassentüren und dann aber ich noch in
diesem und jenem aber das wird man
bastelt ich mache mir keine sorgen dass
ich mich stressen muss um damit fertig
zu werden
aber die türen müssen gemacht werden
schaun schlimm aus wegen dem wetter
ok jungtier fertig hatte ihr kommen
meine räder
das war einfach
[Musik]
drei wochen dauert es bis er und sein
team das schloss winterfest gemacht
haben dann ist er hier allein fast sechs
monate lang
[Musik]
für mich ist das kein albtraum
es ist toll zu sehen wie ein werk und
verschwindet und du dich um den rest der
welt nicht kümmern muss ich genieße die
stille nicht jedoch die kälte die
fenster sind alt und nicht isoliert
daher verschließt er alle im wohnbereich
zusätzlich mit plexiglasscheiben die
kalte luft heute noch draußen halten das
wird toll so ein bisschen kühl gestern
nachdem heute morgen
ich lebe hier schon seit 13 jahren
ich hoffe ich bin noch hier bin ich
sterbe ich habe meinen sohn ist kuriert
dass er dann meine asche hier verstreuen
dann kann ich der geist sein jedes
schloss braucht ein gas
in wenigen wochen werden eis und schnee
das schloss und die insel von der
außenwelt abschneiden
[Musik]
auch auf der kanadischen insel zu gast
ruhiger laufen mittlerweile die
vorbereitungen für sophies jährlichen
kleinen umzug freunde sind gekommen um
zu helfen das haus winterfest zu machen
eine überwinterung auf der insel ist
gerade für ältere menschen für zu
gefährlich
die wintermonate verbringt sie daher in
florida
[Musik]
es wird einsam wenn alle gegangen sind
und dann auch ein bisschen gefährlich
als was passiert weil dann nicht mehr so
viele leute in der nähe der fluss früher
zu aber nicht überall dick genug um in
die stadt zu gehen außer du hast ein
spezielles propeller bot aber es ist
gefährlich und ich denke daher ist es
der familie zuliebe besser dann auf dem
festland zu bleiben doch vorher muss sie
das wasser abdrehen alle möbel zum
schutz vor dem staub abdecken und das
porzellan entfernen eingedrungene vögel
oder eichhörnchen richten sonst in den
unbewohnten haus ein chaos an
die vollblut journalist in kann es kaum
erwarten wieder zurück zu kommen sobald
der frühling beginnt als eine der ersten
selbstverständlich
[Musik]
die assets da passe ich denke es ist
diese leidenschaft auf einer insel zu
leben
du hast deine abgeschiedenheit du musst
keine anderen leute sehen wenn du nicht
willst es ist daher was besonderes es
ist friedlich
ich kann es kaum erwarten wieder
zurückzukommen
[Musik]
kurz nachdem sie ihre insel verlassen
hat fallen die 1000 inseln in den
winterschlaf auch singer kassel haben
eis und schnee fest im griff
der strom selbst friert jedoch immer
seltener zu
das eis zu betreten ist lebensgefährlich
aber auch jetzt zeigen die pausen teilen
ihre atemberaubende schönheit ein
naturwunder im norden amerikas
[Musik]